[Musique]
c'est la première fois tu vas tu as
jamais ça c'est la première fois que
j'essaie de faire sa demande est pas
présente de manière sexy d'ensemble la
salle devrait pas empêcher un esprit de
celui de communiquer avec nous par
internet et à reclasser visualiser nous
on est assis en cercle esprits nous
t'invitons à te servir de nous pour
transmettre tout message est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un avec nous manifeste toi
maintenant
c'était quoi ça et lille s'est inquiété
ce bruit moi j'ai entendu mais je
faisais pas produit attendez je crois
que quelque chose claire
ah
c'est pas drôle
quelque chose on a pris contact avec un
esprit il faut qu'on lui parle il faut
qu'on continue
s'est pas rendue
j'avais dit pas manquer de respect aux
esprits ça peut être une entité des
variables y tout à fait bientôt deux ans
aimar est avec des filtres c'est bon